i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
welcome to fearless
i'm your host tim ferriss and on this
stage we will be deconstructing
world-class performers of all types to
uncover the specific tactics and
strategies they've used to overcome
doubt tackle hard decisions and
ultimately succeed
by show of hands how many people here
wait for say the morning paper to get
their support scores
it's a big fat zero
how many of you can remember when
television wasn't available 24 hours a
day anyone alright of my generation or a
little bit older got a few hands and
when i say bristol connecticut what do
you think of
after meeting my guest tonight you'll
associate it with one thing and that is
sports against all odds he set out to
change the course of television and the
status quo as we know it and in the
process he created one of the most
iconic and recognizable brands in the
world please welcome the founder of espn
bill rasmussen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bill we have so much to talk about i
have so many questions for you i hope
you don't have dinner plans
is that an invitation i think that might
be an invitation but before we get to
all the questions i'd love to ask we
have a video that i want to roll and
then i'd love for you to describe for
people what it actually is okay so let's
take a look
yay verily a sampler of wonders hi i'm
lee leonard welcoming you to bristol
connecticut 110 miles from new york city
why bristol because here in bristol is
where all the sports action is as of
right now now here's another innovation
on espn and it's going to be a big part
of our future the sports center with
george grand he'll have the latest on
what's happening all around george
thanks lee and welcome everyone to the
espn sports center
from this very desk in the coming weeks
and months we'll be filling you in on
the pulse of sporting activity not only
around the country but around the world
as well it takes an interview we'll do
it if it takes play by play we'll do it
if it takes commentary we'll do that too
that's the way we'll function from the
espn sports center and we'll be filling
you in on further updates as the
broadcast progresses
so we're going to delve into of course
the path that led you to that point but
what was the video that we just saw
that was that was opening night and the
the first words that were not there were
about if you're a fan uh we do have that
so we may i can give it to you right
verbatim if you let's let's hear it
verbatim yeah let's go back i'm ready
i'm ready because we were pretty
involved that night as you might imagine
if you're a fan if you're a fan what
you'll see in the next minutes hours and
days to follow may convince you you've
gone to sports heaven
beyond that blue horizon is a limitless
world of sports and right now you're
standing on the edge of tomorrow sports
24 hours a day seven days a week from
espn the total sports cable network
so that's better than tape isn't it so
this this i guess leads me to one of my
very first questions i've read that you
were obsessed with sports as a kid
did you have an impeccable memory for
different aspects of sports but what
type of obsession was it
well it all started
this is a very appropriate time to be
talking about this
but since the cubs have finally won are
there any cub fans around we have to
[Music]
my grandfather actually saw all six
games of the 1906 world series when the
white sox beat the cubs the only
all-chicago world series ever
and he talked to me about baseball
and and the white sox because i was
living on the south side
from a very young age
and before i knew it i had a glove in my
hand and a ball in my hand and then by
the time i was in the fifth grade i was
playing an organized games and it just
i've always been obsessed with it and
for some reason i have a memory for
statistics
and i can you know
we can talk about the cubs or the white
sox or whatever and names stick in my
head
from
days when i was living in chicago and
the cubs didn't have
chris brian at third base they had stan
hack at third base and they didn't have
rizzo at first base they had phil
cavaretta at first but i mean
and it's just always been there i don't
know why and do you remember your first
baseball game that you saw on television
or your first
media experience
on uh
television or otherwise
it was 1947 the yankees were playing the
white sox
and
my father i had played a game somewhere
my father said let's stop i want to show
you something because one of the local
establishments
quote unquote
had a tv and they were gonna that was
1947
must have been wgn probably uh doing the
the game the picture was about this big
and it was in the cabinet about as big
as the dresser in your bedroom so be
like if you took your smartphone and
just put it on your wall that's sort of
that's basically what the tv looked like
yeah
that's about it size-wise tell me a
little bit more about your father he was
always encouraging he encouraged all of
us we were all going to get
a college education i was the first one
in the entire family he was the 11th of
11 children i was the first one to get
to graduate from college and always 100
supportive but i'll tell you he was a
real task master
the deal was my
two brothers and sister used to come
with me if i
would pile in the car if i was playing
game because it was we're all going to
support bill you know and that was great
and if i got a hit we would all get a
soft ice cream
cone on the way home
so i had a lot of real supporters on the
side there on you know on the sideline
two brothers and sister
and if i didn't get a hit my father
would drive the same route and he
wouldn't even take his foot off the gas
he'd drive right by
and my brothers and sister would just be
all over me what did you do why didn't
you you know you should have run faster
for this you should have done that why
did you swing and miss why did you
struggle over you at the time this is
kind of yeah i made a picture for us
this is i'm in the 14 or 15 year old yes
so that's a very i might maybe i'm just
projecting here but you know 14 15 16 i
was a very
i didn't hadn't found my footing in the
world that that type of pressure would
be
not not terrible but just a
a real thing to consider did you
how did you did that affect how you
played or did you say anything to
yourself before no i just i just always
want to get a hit you know everybody
wants to get a hit yeah everybody wants
to bet a thousand nobody can yeah that's
just the way it is and some days you go
four for four and some days you go over
four and if we jump to college what did
you think you were going to be you know
when we were in college the only thing
we all knew was we were going to go on
active duty in the service we had no
there was no thought about what was
going to happen next we and that was
literal
our choices were
unlike many years later
we had we did have choices four choices
do you want to be called active duty
september 15th november 15th january
15th or march 15th that was it
wow turns out they didn't they didn't
really mean that they just took you when
they wanted and my name came up in
november and
do you know how hard it is you've
graduated from college you want to go to
do something work
gainfully somewhere
and they say well what about sir well
yeah actually i have to go on active
duty on november 15th
no jobs i mean i graduated on june 6th
and i ended up uh actually
being a
i'm not even sure what you call it but i
was
unloading trucks of produce at night at
the local grocery store that was all you
couldn't get a job
but nobody minded because that was what
we had to do that was during the korean
war of course
now if if you hadn't been in during war
time
had you thought of or was baseball even
a prospect oh yeah oh i was gonna play
third base for the white sox man look
out i was gonna do it but you don't mean
that as say you know a third grader
saying someday i'm going to be a
professional baseball player you
actually have the chops oh no i was i
was going to play that's all there was
to it i
i could run and feel and one summer we
were playing a summer league and an
unknown then and now
could have been record was
i never got caught steven the whole
season and so we were in the last game
of the season i thought if i steal one
more i didn't have to run i hadn't been
caught all season if i get one you know
i always want to get one more
that's going to be pretty cool and the
game and the season nobody's ever done
that
man i had second base stolen i said i've
done it i let up for one second
whap ball was there and i was gone i was
out
from that moment and i can feel that
moment right now sitting here talking to
you tim
i let myself down and i've never done
that i want to go all the way through
the finish line
every time and i and i i think of that
lesson
and i thought about that in business i
thought about that when i was in the air
force and sitting here today talking to
you just keeping your eye on the ball
keep your eye on the ball keep focused
never never let up until you're
accomplished what you want to do
and that's the difference right i mean
it's the last that last two percent
which separates
maybe it's the last two tenths or two
100s whatever it is how did that
translate to after college i mean you
have a very long resume you did a lot of
different jobs but
how did that say translate to whether
it's the air force or the business world
well when i started i got out of the air
force in uh november 1956 and went to
work for westinghouse right after the
first of the year and was it at
westinghouse that you started to learn
about
advertising television things like that
yep it was and i was working in the
advertising department
and one of the things to answer your
preceding question was
the sales department would go out and
the sales manager would have all of
these
this was a national company obviously
they were all i don't know they had
say 14 12 or 14 districts across the
country or regions
and they would go out and set up this
great program get all of the materials
printed
get all the uh the corrugated
displays printed get everything in ready
and the problem was that this
program would be introduced and it'd be
14 weeks later before they got the
material for the program
so i went to the advertising manager and
i said i have a great idea
i said we've got to improve this and
i'll i did are you familiar with carbon
interleaved forms does that never ring
does that even carbon inner leaf form
these like triplicates they leave an
impression i'm just guessing here that's
exactly what it was all right and so i
said let's make one and we'll color code
them one for this they had the large
lamp division the automotive vision the
photo photo division so
different colors for each one so if
you're a guy who's selling photo lamps
you send in the right color
we've got three copies and we'll you
know
still didn't improve things so i said
tell you what i'll quit and start a
business and we'll do that and the
business was ad 8 inc started in 1959.
it lasted it may still be there but i
know in 50 years later it was still
functioning in kearney new jersey so you
identified the need within a business
while you were still getting paid and
then offered to solve it by starting
your own business by quitting and
starting my own you already had a
customer before you even started we did
your business and we made you talk about
making decisions about business
of course you know we stepped out and we
had westinghouse we said well we'll see
who else can do it we went down the
street you know small business here
small business here small
decided that wasn't the way to go
because small businesses are more of a
pain in the neck to take care of
and try to collect your money
really tough whereas westinghouse
the end of the month check arrived
automatically
so we decided we would stop talking to
the little businesses and we went to uh
well we went to general electric we went
to snh green stamps which was a big
company at the time general foods all
the big companies they said great idea
and you know what
never had it never had a default after
that
so we learned another lesson
do business with people who are good
business people
and actually have the funds in the
budget to make it work this became a
gigantic operation i mean it seems like
it was an immediate hit
and how did you segue then from this to
broadcasting
this was
pretty repetitive every day you go in
and you have a big order and you fill it
and they pay you and so on and and i was
getting old i was approaching 30. i
didn't
i didn't want my life to go by without
something
well when i found out i couldn't play
baseball i decided that i could become a
broadcaster now i had no radio
experience obviously because all i've
been in the air force in westinghouse
and this
i'm not sure if you've seen a magazine
called broadcasting and they used to run
little two-line ads like little want ads
there was one for sportscaster in
westerly rhode island and i can remember
just as we're sitting here now walking
in
hi how are you and so on and
did you bring a tape
oh
didn't bring a tape no
well what station worked for never
worked for a radio station
he said well
you wrote you you answered this thing
for a sportscaster he said why do you
think you can be a sportscaster because
i know i can do it
he said you're kidding me you don't have
a tape you've never done it but you know
you can do it
i said yep
he said you know what based based on
this approach i'm putting a news station
on the air in amherst massachusetts
and if you'll help me put it on the air
you're my sportscaster
hold on
hit pause for a second
so
the
so the the force of will sort of
should spa right that that
that just willed that into existence
there's got to be a little bit more to
it did you just stare them down or was
it you you let the silence do the work i
mean i think it well no i just told my
story and i guess it was just the
silence and he pondered not very long
yeah and
what i didn't realize is his station was
going on the air this is now
october
he said i'll start you january 1st
because they were going to have to do
field strength testing of the signal and
so on right what i didn't realize was
amherst massachusetts in january the
snow was about hip deep and you had to
go out into the farm fields and hold up
this little you know
can you hear me now one of those kind of
things
and so we did that and uh we went on the
air on april 1st did you have to do that
yeah that's that that was my that was
part of the game that was part of the
gig yeah so i had to go do that
and we went on the air april first and
then i
university of massachusetts was located
still is in amherst massachusetts it was
a small school and of about 10 000
students i almost went to amherst i mean
great great school
so i said why don't we do umass football
guy he didn't care he wasn't a sports
fan he said you know i hired you as a
sports guy so i went up
and i met the introduce myself the
athletic director hi
warren mcgurk was his name hi i'm bill
rasmussen local radio station
we'd really like to talk to you about
doing your football games he said you
want to do the games go ahead
i said
i didn't say it to him i said to myself
what are you just saying go ahead
no requirement for uh discussion no
requirement for a contract and
especially no rights fee
so off we went and got the rights to do
umass football but of course i had never
done a football game because i had never
done any radio before i got there so
how'd that go what about what was your
first first game your first game like
it was fun
it was it was the university of
massachusetts at the university of maine
in orono maine
we didn't have anybody else at the
station so
i've been talking to their sports
information people and the direct sports
information director
a veteran who'd been there for some 20
years
said he would be my color guy
so all the way from from amherst to
orono maine i was thinking
should i tell him i've never done a
football game before
worse yet should i tell him i've never
even seen a college football game live
before
i said nah
extraneous yeah let's still figure that
out on his own let's just go for it so
that's what we did we just went in and
started talking
not a problem never heard a word uh
massachusetts 114 to nothing
we drove all the way back and he never
said a word and
about
i didn't know you hadn't done this or
didn't nothing i never said anything and
he didn't ask don't tell
experience he didn't say anything i
didn't say anything we did the whole
season it was it was great
i mean if you if you don't try you never
get anywhere no i agree i have to try
[Music]
when i do something new i like to try a
lot of new things i'm a novelty seeker
and
very frequently unqualified for whatever
it is that i'm
trying to do a very good friend of mine
said once a very successful investor he
said if i always did what i was
qualified to do i'd be pushing a broom
somewhere
and
i
really believe that at the same time
i
get a little nervous maybe before doing
something especially publicly that i
haven't done before did you have any
type of
what is your self-talk like if anything
i mean what is that i i just warm up
it's kind of like a movie in my head i
know it's gonna work i've already seen
it up here before it happens you're
visualizing it yeah you have to prepare
and i do that to this day if i'm going
someplace to to do something that
requires
specifics all of all the specific front
works backwards and
and all of those specifics around it
before we get started
and as you mentioned earlier for some
reason i've been blessed with a really
good memory
well lots of powerful assets have also i
mean just as in terms of types of memory
for your chosen field it was a very nice
it was a very good one yeah
and
you have i mean you've winged it a fair
amount which i i mean as a compliment uh
with preparation not a fair amount
a lot a lot a lot okay all right
i won't hedge i think a lot of people
who are watching might think
oh my god this guy is just exuding more
confidence than i have seen in every
extended member of my family combined so
they might say oh this guy has no
weaknesses he's never had any self-doubt
what is one of those things that that
wasn't part of the highlight reel
well getting fired is always kind of a
traumatic moment is there a particular
getting fired
well the one that the one that's most
particular to me was getting fired i i
was uh with the new england whalers of
the world hockey association
for four years in the mid 70s
they the world hockey association had
been around for four years and they'd
been in the playoffs won the
championship one year and were in the
playoffs and in
1977-78 they missed the playoffs and you
know when a team misses the playoffs
after all that success they have to have
some changes
they fired everybody in the front office
me included none of us had by the way
skated one stride for the team that lost
all of
all those games and missed the playoffs
that was memorial day weekend following
we got supposed to do a tv show to talk
about the whalers past and the whaler's
future with a guy in in hartford
and i called him and said you know what
you probably don't want to talk to me
because and he said yeah yeah we're
going to do the show i said no i don't
think so because i was just fired he
said well you got to come down and talk
to me i don't have anybody else to talk
to us so come on down
so i went down and saw him that first
week in june we began to talk about uh
maybe doing some connecticut basketball
or maybe
maybe why not the whole state of
connecticut why not add wesleyan and
yale and
fairfield and so on
and that was that was a really great
idea i mean there was no big east end so
he said okay so right away i said okay
we got to figure out how to hook them
together i knew how to put a
a network together because telco i'd
done it with radio in massachusetts and
with the whalers and so on so
i called uh
snepco southern new england telephone
company
and the guy's name was build something i
remember that i can't remember his last
name now
but i told him what i wanted to do
connecticut had all of five cable
systems operating that's all five
i said i wanted to hook them all
together so we could do a broadcast
from one point to all of them at the
same time
how much it's going to cost simple
question put them together tell me how
much it's going to cost the more
he said well you're getting a cart ahead
of the horse here he said
it's going to take us some time to put
together and we have to go through and
do a
an evaluation or something i said well
how long is i think it's going to be you
know 48 hours i'll have an answer he
said well it takes about 18 months to do
this
i said it takes what he said 18 months
so i
went back and said
this isn't going to work it's going to
take 18 months
he was officing at the plainville
connecticut
branch of united cable was headquartered
in denver and the general manager is
talking one day and he said you know
what
he said i
i don't know about that idea of yours
hooking all the cables together he said
but here's something you might look into
rca has got this thing called a
satellite nobody seems to know much
about it
but i've got the phone number for rca
americana new york i'll just give it to
you you call them and you figure it out
so i said i'd like to speak with someone
about nrc america i'm about time on one
of your satellites oh yes sir wait a
minute i'll get you somebody the guy
came on said help her now may i help you
said yeah i just i
briefly described what he wanted to do
and he said where are you in connecticut
i thought wow this is pretty good
i told him and he said i'll be up there
tomorrow morning
now we didn't have an office where are
you going to come up to
so this is one of another one of those
what do you mean you don't have a tape
situations like that so i just so we
went down and i talked to the vice
president giving me the number he got me
into it so yeah i said can we use your
conference room very nicely appointed
conference room they spent a lot of
money putting together he said we have a
company policy i have to charge you for
and i thought oh boy
he said well 20 bucks be too much so he
gave him a 20 bill and we had a
conference
room and he came up and explained
everything and at the end of his whole
presentation he said there's one thing
that we used to offer but we don't
anymore because nobody has ever been
interested in it 24 hours a day
seven days a week and it's a five year
contract thirty four thousand one
hundred sixty seven dollars a month
okay and so he went off and my son scott
and i started talking about that
overnight we called him the next morning
and it was really a funny competition
the next morning so i didn't know the
difference between satellite
transponder and all that
you know jargon
so i just called and i said to him al
we'll take one of those
he said one of what
that thing you're talking about that you
know what you did just about what i did
because i at my desk i went one of those
things that
transplanted that satellite thing we
were talking about he said you mean a
transponder yeah that's what i mean
and that started it
so he said you've got it
we'll paper it over obviously
so that was all we needed we went down
into uh
hartford the capital of connecticut
incorporated espn on bastille day july
14 1978
off we went so we've talked a lot about
satellites transponders everything in
between i'll take one of those so i
thought it would be fun to bring up a
video that explains how some of this
works
years ago tales of jules verne and buck
rogers were made of dreams and wild bits
of imagination today modern technology
has taken those dreams and that
imagination and turned it into a reality
that allows us to bring a television
picture into your home via satellite the
picture you're watching right now has
been taken by a camera sent through some
sophisticated equipment to this earth
transmitting station which in turn feeds
a satellite located 22 300 miles above
the equator just south of hawaii our
cameraman takes a picture at a football
stadium for example that picture is fed
into our espn remote truck out of the
remote truck to an earth transmitting
station up to the satellite over the
equator back down to an earth receiving
station over a cable in your hometown
into your television set in your living
room
technology
so everybody got it that was like
virtual reality back in the day
all right
one take two by the way that was the
only take because it was 6 30 and we
were going on the air in 30 minutes
they said don't mess it up don't mess it
up
so espn uh
what was the original incarnation you
said you incorporated it
uh when you incorporated it what in your
mind was espn and how did you choose how
did you choose the name we knew we were
going to do 24-hour sports at that point
we had we had made that decision and a
colleague there's a partner in an
advertising firm one of their clients
was the connecticut natural gas company
who was running a
promo
for an energy
saving program recognize the letters e s
p
to do animation in those days was very
very expensive and we had no money we
started this whole thing with a nine
thousand dollar credit card cash advance
so you know you you have to husband your
dollars
they had this great graphic and there
was
something circling the globe and here
was you know clouds and all this motion
and they had done it it said esp esp
going around
and so he called and he said you know i
think you guys have a great idea i'd
like to come to work for you and i said
you know we couldn't hire anybody
i said i'll tell you what
that that connecticut natural gas thing
if you can bring that
graphic minus the you know no audio just
bring that graphic and we can put our
own words to it
you're hired he called me the next
morning he said when do i start i nearly
fell over i couldn't believe he'd pull
it off he got permission from
connecticut and natural gas to take the
stuff that they had paid for
the graphic the visual
and brought it to us
and so we had the esp well
that wasn't going to work we you know we
thought we would be the uh spn sports
programming network but somebody already
had a satellite programming network so
we couldn't use it
so he had the e on the front end and we
figured we could add the n on the back
end and
and we'll see
that the original version of espn was
the e period s period p period network
and it was a kooky looking logo i have
to tell you
and uh it sounds a lot like registering
these days you know websites domains
you're like well that one's taken this
is what i'm saying well if you had a
letter here subtract one here add
another one there yeah so now it's time
to move ahead and we're looking for
funds you
got a nice chunk of change we can talk
about i think it was nine thousand
thirty thousand kind of family and
friends correct me from wrong yeah
that's right and then getty
of course there was an interim step in
there's an interim step what happened we
had some appointments with some very
very big and powerful companies uh the
pittsburgh plate class people
the campbell soup foundation we i mean
they were big companies and
yeah with staff broadcasting do you
remember that
they went out of business i don't know
at what point along the way anyway
we went out there i visited with them
they i actually met with the board and
the chairman hosted me we had a
delightful lunch
we talked a little bit and then he
walked me to the front door and out into
the parking lot for my rental car and he
said
we really appreciate you coming i mean
figuratively you know patting me on the
head and saying
you're a delightful young man thank you
for coming today but i have to tell you
your ideas simply will not work
oh and one other thing he said there
will be no cable television three years
from today
taft broadcasting went out of business i
just don't remember when
cable television's live and well
how did how did you feel when he
said that to you and dismissed you in
the parking lot i thought he made a
mistake he was a nice man i wasn't going
to say anything nasty to him i wasn't i
had no negative reaction to him i just
knew he was wrong i just thought he made
a mistake he had a great opportunity and
they might still be around today if he
had made the right decision
that sounds that sounds crappy i didn't
mean it though
but that was the sixth company we'd been
to and then we ended up coming out to
getty oil met with a vice president and
explained the whole thing and he was
very skeptical and so on
but what i didn't know is that he was a
gentleman who
really liked
the idea
because it was putting him close to
television and he lived in hollywood and
all this kind of stuff
and many many years later this finance
manager told me he said you don't know
this
but his office was on the 18th floor and
he called me when he left his office and
he said i swear before you got
the elevator got to the bottom floor
he had called me and said george we're
going in the television business
because he wanted to be in a television
business
was this a chicken in the egg issue were
you basically saying we've
getty family is totally behind us we got
this nailed down so you should really
give us the programming and then oh no
it wasn't just those two it was you've
seen the jugglers who can throw five of
them in the air at the same time
if here's and this literally happened if
we were talking to getty
we were doing very well with rca and the
satellite although we hadn't signed a
contract yet
but they were contractually obligated to
you because they put the paper down yeah
nice good move we are making a lot of
progress with the cable operators we
have well how many they never asked how
many we had signed early on but we were
making a lot of progress with them uh
and programming with the ncaa it's a
natural for the ncaa now if we're
talking to the ncaa they say well how
are you going to finance this oh we're
talking to getty oil they are 100 behind
this as a matter of fact their finance
manager is coming in the next meeting so
we can explain all that and it just went
like that and of course we were talking
to the cable operators it was we've got
the financing with getty we've got the
programming with
the ncaa and all we need is you to let
your your subscribers know
and they will be fans of ours and
customers of yours and increase your
you know
so so the programming though i mean
that's the the life that's the key in a
lot of ways i mean you need the capital
but you also need the programming so
this is a good point to talk about
something we have here that i'm not
going to open up and we're going to get
you you have a broken arm if you open
the house yeah i can't open this this is
a shrink-wrapped copy of the original
espn pitch deck to the ncaa hey why is
this shrink wrapped
and then b can you describe hand it to
me i'll show you what we did all right
this is really easy
we had a very creative printer and he
was very much on our side helping us get
things done
and i don't know if you can see what
this says he said i'm going to design
this for you because you don't know what
you're doing i said okay and i said
we've got to get these copies out to the
ncaa and they said no no no i'm not uh
you cannot do that he printed six copies
shrink-wrapped all of them and i said
why are we shrink-wrapping him he said
because if you put an open book in front
of somebody in a meeting they will begin
to flip through it before you finish
saying what you have to say that's very
smart if you put a shrink wrap book in
front of them
they won't they'll be looking right and
left until somebody else starts to open
it they won't touch theirs and you get
to finish your story and then you cue
them and say now
open your presentation and then we walk
through it that is very smart and i've
used this as an example i can't tell you
how many times
it's a very very effective tool
it's amazing that is that this because
i've seen so many pitches
i mean in my other life i do a lot of uh
investing in early tech mostly and i've
seen so many dozens of pitches fail
because what happens is exactly what you
said people start flipping ahead
they're busy they're distracted and
they're not listening at all to what the
person is saying and before that person
can get two sentences in they've already
found an objection and it's game over
so what then tell us more about the
pitch meeting with the ncaa so what were
what were other keys of the pitch well
at first the first meeting was in
october when we presented this book so
he said well i'll have to talk to walter
about this but he said the best thing
you can do is keep working through the
tv committee so we went to a
tv committee meeting in october we went
to another one in december
we went to another one in january and
i'm getting tired of going to tv
meetings we don't seem to i've never
seen walter byers at this point i still
haven't seen him
on january 25th we're at the kansas city
marriott airport
doing yet another tv committee meeting
and the back door of the uh meeting room
opens and it's walder buyers he comes in
sits down right in the middle of a
sentence doesn't say excuse me doesn't
say
and he doesn't have it quite he just
comes in sits down he'll see her there
he is yeah where he is he's there so he
i kept talking
i mean literally i kept talking and he
stood up and he said how do i right in
the middle of no introduction i mean
everybody knew who he was he said
how do i know that you're not just on a
fishing exposition you're just looking
to use our name to go out and raise some
money
i and to this minute sitting here
talking to you tim i don't know why i
said it or where it came from but i said
you give us the name of your bank and on
july 1st we'll deposit 50 of whatever
amount we come to an agreement
sat back down
two guys next to me jb doherty
from ksuite and george connor the
financial guy from getty turned about as
white as this table
and
worse than that waller gets up walks out
the back door and slams the door and
leaves
i was sure it was all over
uh coppage adjourned the meeting tom
hansen came up and said
walter wondered if you could stay over
another night and come out to the office
and meet with us
and that started that was january 25th
by march 1st we had a written contract
signed
so let's
let's talk a little bit about
um
the launch itself
so you get these pieces of the puzzle
arranged
uh you managed to juggle successfully
and you have these incredible
commitments and by the way i want to
just underscore something for folks
it seems like
and please feel free to jump in but you
can you can get really really far in
life further near you than you would
expect just by asking why not i've
noticed you brought that up a couple
times like
why not what's worse that could happen
and
uh
the launch though i really want to dig
into so between signing all of these
folks getting all these commitments
and your first air date how much time
elapsed uh we signed the ncaa on march
1.
we hired chet simmons from nbc he came
on board july 31st
we were signing subscribers cable
subscribers multiple system operators
all through that period
chet came on board on july 31st and we
said we're going on the year september
7th and he said no we're not because the
building hadn't even topped they hadn't
even finished
the walls of the building to the point
where they could put the tree on top and
say well this is high as we're going you
know chet was convinced we couldn't go
on but the contractor said we'll have it
ready for you and they did there's
that's kind of a picture of what it
looked like now that looks like the same
tie that we saw in that video earlier
was that the same day
no well yeah we finished the building by
6 30 no that wasn't the same day but it
probably was the same time
so we have a photo of you guys in the
control room behind the scenes you could
see how positive we all were yeah
so what is the conversation happening in
this room when you guys are doing this
first broadcast that particular moment
there wasn't a word being said
but in general were there uh what was
paint a picture for us yeah we
picture at 6 30 at night we're going
around the air at seven we hadn't
recorded some of these things by that
time so there was a little bit of angst
building among people and we still had
the contractor outside cleaning windows
because we had all glass windows so
people could see into the control room
into here and there and speaking of the
master control room next to the studio
to run the show it didn't work espn
actually wanted the air from a remote
truck out behind the building we were on
the air with espn for about a month from
the remote truck out back which is kind
of funny but that's that's the way it
was what were some of the
with espn some of the the best
and worst decisions that you made
i think the best decision was
sportscenter yep
i mean
you have to understand the context of
the day abc nbc and cbs they uh
commanded 93 of the audience at 6 30.
that i mean america 3 93 america tuned
in to the evening news
and we said we were going to put
sportscenter out at 6 30. what what do
you think the first reaction was from
everybody
outside of our
enthusiastic little bunch
you're crazy you're crazy
they have 93 i said but the other seven
percent will watch us
what do you mean the other seven well
maybe they're sports fans
fast forward many many years and i don't
know what it is today but i know it's
under 15 percent watch the big three
networks and of course there are a lot
more channels and so on i don't know
what the
i know there are many nights that sports
center has and depending on what's
happening in the sports world they
produce some pretty big numbers
so you have a lot of hours to fill 24
hours it's a lot of hours and so you had
to in some cases
really slot in a wide spectrum of
different sports so i thought it would
be fun to take a look at just a handful
of those sports from penn state
university espn brings you the ncaa
championship fencing
so
we go into event number three of the day
bruno the saber and this one's kind of a
throwback to the old movies of the
swashbuckling pirates and the three
musketeers next division three cross
country championships enjoy it
ncaa championship cross country on espn
today from the duran eastman golf course
in rochester new york it's the division
three championships
and you had some very
esoteric i was going to use the word
esoteric it's hard to believe we turned
anything down right
we had a group from new york city come
to us and ask us what rights fee we
would pay them
to televise their new york city rooftop
platform tennis league
[Laughter]
so you were receiving the pitch in this
case yes and we said uh i don't think so
we we had a lot a lot of people
presented serious uh proposals
but that one was probably the farthest
out in
that was not in left field that was in
deep left field and farther it was gone
perhaps this is a good place to ask just
for people who are wondering
uh
when did you leave espn
it was sold
okay so i can tell you exactly when i
left it was 205 pm friday afternoon june
25th 1984.
bill rasmussen
and the reason
they had it that's a big check
yeah so from from memorial day 1978 to
june 25th 1984 was my
active tenure with uh
with espn
do you ever regret having left do you
wish you could have stayed longer not
for a second and i think of all of the
things that have happened
the
creation of literally hundreds of
thousands of jobs for freelance people
for network people for all the teams
have their own networks now and
basically espn spawned all of that
and
i'm really proud of that i'm pleased if
somebody wanted to get good at
negotiating or just pitching like this
do you have any particular
recommendations for them i know i have a
few books that had a huge impact on me
i'll share what those are but do you
have any any recommendations i think one
you have to know as much as you can
possibly know about your subject the
other thing is i don't have to know all
the details about your business what are
your goals and what's your general
business
i don't have to know all the details
about my business
where do we want to go and where do we
want to take it i'm not a i'm not an
engineer i'm not a mathematician i'm not
an accountant i'm none of those things
but i kind of have an idea to put the
idea together and have a general
knowledge
of some statistics that make some sense
well you have a really good combination
of a number of things and i remember at
one point reading an article by a
gentleman named mark andreessen so marc
andreessen is a billionaire he was
co-author of the mosaic web browser so
the first really popular graphic web
browser
and he noted that most ceos
are kind of in the top 20
in two or three
fields but they're very rarely the
michael jordan of just one thing you
have to have a few overlapping skills
and the good news is it's a lot easier
it's a lot easier to plan that and
engineer that in your life than it is to
try to aim to be that one michael jordan
yeah uh
so the books i was going to mention for
you guys if you're interested i found
very helpful getting past no a little
more realistic than getting to yes in my
opinion and then secrets of power
negotiating i would get the audio if you
can because you can tell with the
cadence of bill's voice and the delivery
there's a lot of nuance
let's see if we can pull up some some
audience questions this is from lex uh
how does it feel to have captured the
attention of so many people and our
boyfriends and bring them together
through sports well it wasn't always
that way in our early days
some of the men in the audience
got so enamored with espn
that we were on the air barely a year
and we were named in a divorce action
a lady in texas included us because her
husband was paying more attention to
espn than he was to her
and when it arrived in bristol our
general counsel
and our whole legal department was only
one person so our general counsel went
oh my we're dead what's going to happen
and our pr lady said we want to spell
her name right and she put out a press
release
and that turned out to be the first of
many times es men has been frequently
named in divorce suits
for alienation of whatever i i don't get
it but addictive entertainment addictive
entertainment
aside from
family members when you hear the word
successful who is the first person who
comes to mind
successful
success is described in so many
different ways when i think back to my
father surviving
the depression getting four kids through
college coming through world war ii that
was a success
what is success to you
getting a good night's sleep i guess
you know
so this seriously when you get older
you'll find no no no i i do take it
seriously because i've always had onset
insomnia and by the way jody foster i
think has said success is sleeping well
like it's
it's a good indicator of what you're
doing right what you're doing wrong well
and you have so much more energy the
next day to do
more things do you feel like a success
not really you know i'm just a guy from
the south side of chicago i i'm i've
been blessed to be involved in a lot of
really good things that turned out well
but i don't uh
you know i don't walk down the street in
my espn jacket across the back or
anything
if you had to give
a high-prior profile talk 20-minute talk
on something that is not something
you're known for like espn
avid avid reader and i'm a
a serious advocate and a serious
uh student of american history
all the way back to the civil war but
particularly in world war ii and
just because i lived through it i mean i
lived through the military part of it i
was in the high schools in chicago were
all military
uh they all had rotc units we had
the various and sundry parades were all
you know and it just
especially living in the world war ii
period you got such a sense of country
and patriotism
if somebody wanted to immerse themselves
in that if you had
friend student doesn't really matter
someone who really wanted to immerse
themselves in that history
what books would you recommend they
start with or any places to start the
first one i would
and i i'm now reading it for the second
time so um
and it's a little book it's 789 pages
you have to immerse i mean you have to
really get into it
it's called december 1941. and if you
read that book you'll find out so much
about
politics war america and the resiliency
of this country
it's just it's an amazing amazing book
what are what are your
current challenges or if you had to pick
one of your current challenges
or problems that you're facing we're
starting a new business
it's called hometown that works and what
we're going to do is we we have been
i've been an advisor to a company that
has come up with an incredible i don't
know how they do this stuff
it's one single 4k camera one microphone
and a little black box
you can produce any baseball game
football game hockey game whatever you
want soccer game
and he wants to do it for high schools
all across america or secondary schools
there's town rec uh recreational areas
and so on
i think it's a great idea so i've agreed
to help them
so if i were to if i were to ask you
then what's next for bill rasmussen that
would be
a big component of it
sounds like yeah that's what i'm doing
now because i
first of all
you talk about four hour work weeks
while i
you're pushing the envelope there
getting aggressive getting extreme well
no no but i but i really i don't i don't
want to work at it for and i don't work
for i
i don't work full-time in the sense that
people think of going to work right work
up here because you're thinking about
things
but i think
it's a great opportunity for
not only youngsters playing but for
parents for grandparents for relatives
anywhere
streaming goes anywhere in the world now
if i have a if i have a kid playing in
uh florida and you're living in
california
and you say what's you know sam up to
today tune in tonight you can find him
you'll watch them
make sure that all those people who are
going to benefit from this
aren't all about it and that's what
we're doing all about it so i only have
i only have two questions left if
there's anything you would like to
say as parting comments recommendation
suggestion
thoughts for people are going out on
their own adventures careers maybe
they're just getting started
so i think it's really simple in my view
when i look at a new business
it doesn't get very complicated it's a
short business statement hopefully a
mission statement hopefully no more than
six words and then follow the facts five
facts need financing advertising
content technology and customers
subscribers customers that's we used in
espn i think the same thing works to
this very day you keep it that simple
you'll win one of the patterns that it
seems has come up a number of times here
that is is worth mentioning is that
it seems like for the most important
decisions for doing the big things the
timing's never really good like the
timing's never perfect there's always
something not ready there's always
someone who's walking out the door
there's always a partner who's leaving
there's always something so if you wait
until the timing is
perfect or when it feels really good
you're never gonna be ready you're never
gonna be ready you just have to be right
you have to move when you're ready to go
and
everybody else has to catch up or walk
alongside you one or the other
or as ted turner says lead follower get
out of the way
that's that's he's right he's right to
the point so you guys are both to the
point and you like six words a lot i
don't know if this will end up being six
words but if you had a gigantic
billboard
and can put anything on it then of
course what i'm asking is really if you
get a short message out to
a huge audience what would you put on
that billboard abc nbc
nbc so yeah back to six words again yeah
and back to the two networks i work for
always be curious never be complacent oh
that's a good one
abc nbc
phil rasmussen everybody he's not done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you